>> Greg: HAPPY THURSDAY,
EVERYONE.
KAT IS OFF TODAY.
BUT JULIE BANDERAS IS SITTING IN
FOR HER.
[APPLAUSE]
WHICH DEFINITELY INCREASES THE
AVERAGE BLOOD ALCOHOL CONTENT
FOR THE PANEL.
WE WENT FROM .05 TO THE POINT OF
NO RETURN.
PETE HEGSETH IS HERE.
[APPLAUSE]
GOOD TO SEE HE IS RELAXING HIS
DIMPLES AND TOOK SOME TIME OFF
FROM PARENTING.
HE HAS SO MANY CHILDREN, HE AND
HIS WIFE JUST BOUGHT A NEW
HOUSE.
[LAUGHTER]
SO, BIG NEWS, A REPUBLICAN HAS
GOTTEN A HOUSE SEAT IN THE DEEP
BLUE SOUTH TEXAS.
THAT IS SCARY TO DEMS WHO
THOUGHT THE ONLY SEAT FLIPPING
WOULD BE A GENDER-NEUTRAL
BATHROOM.
IS THIS AN INDICATOR OF A COMING
ROADWAY OF?
MAY BE, AND IT'S GOT NOTHING TO
DO WITH THE TAMPON SHORTAGE.
TERRIBLE.
ABSOLUTELY TERRIBLE.
I DON'T STAND FOR THAT KIND OF
HUMOR.
LET'S ASK THE FOLKS AT
"THE VIEW," WHICH NO ONE HAS
EVER SAID IN THE HISTORY OF THE
UNIVERSE, IS THERE A RED WAVE
COMING?
>> THE RED WAVE IS COMING.
REPUBLICANS ARE GOING TO WIN THE
MIDTERMS, SHORT OF SOMETHING
UNFORESEEN THAT I COULD NOT
PREDICT NOW.
>> YOU DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> LET'S WAIT AND SEE WHAT THE
PEOPLE VOTE IN.
>> Greg: YEAH, YOU KNOW WHAT I
LOVE ABOUT "THE VIEW"?
IT REMINDS PEOPLE EVERY DAY NOT
TO EAT LEAD PAINT CHIPS.
BUT YOU'VE GOT TO REMEMBER,
JOY BEHAR THOUGHT THAT HER GOING
ON A SEX STRIKE WOULD MAKE MEN
CHANGE THEIR MINDS, AND THEY
DID, TO VOTE REPUBLICAN.
LOOK AT REPUBLICAN -- SHE WON
THAT SEAT IN SOUTH TEXAS, THE
FIRST WIN THERE IN 150 YEARS.
THAT IS A LONG TIME.
IT IS LIKE TWO JULIE BANDERASS.
[LAUGHTER]
OR A HALF A JOE BIDEN.
SHE FLIPPED AND 84% HISPANIC
DISTRICT READ AND I BET IT IS
BECOME THE LIBERAL POLICIES FROM
WASHINGTON ARE TEARING OUR
COMMUNITY APART.
SPEAK WITH LIBERAL POLICIES FROM
WASHINGTON ARE TEARING OUR
COMMUNITY APART.
AS THE WIFE OF A BORDER PATROL
AGENT, I PRAY FOR HIS SAFETY
MORE THAN EVER.
WE MUST KEEP OUR SALES KNOW MY
FAMILY SAFE.
>> Greg: SHE IS NOT ONLY SMART
BUT ATTRACTIVE, WHO DOES SHE
REMIND ME OF IN THAT REGARD?
[LAUGHTER]
HER SEAT WAS PREVIOUSLY HELD BY
DEMOCRAT WHO STEPS DOWN TO
BECOME A LOBBYIST AFTER
REALIZING HE WOULD LOSE IN A RED
WAVE, SO HE TOOK THE EASY WAY
OUT, LIKE WHEN I HIDE BEHIND
TYRUS TO AVOID KILMEADE IN THE
HALLWAY.
NOW THE FIRST CONGRESSWOMAN EVER
TO BE BORN IN MEXICO.
SO I AM SURE AOC MUST FIND THAT
THIS HISTORIC FIRST PRETTY
EMPOWERING, SO LET'S GO TO HER
FOR COMMENT.
[LAUGHTER]
AND YOU HEAR THAT ELON MUSK
VOTED FOR FLORES WHICH PROMPTED
JAMAAL BOWMAN TO ACCUSE MUSK OF
SUPPORTING WHITE SUPREMACY.
YEAH, THAT IS LOGIC.
VOTE FOR A WOMAN OF COLOR, WHO
WAS BORN IN MEXICO, AND THAT
MAKES YOU RACIST.
IF JAMAAL GOT ANY DUMBER, HE
COULD BE ON "THE VIEW."
FLORES EARNED AN ENDORSEMENT
FROM GOVERNOR GREG ABBOTT, AND
GUESS WHO IS TRAILING HIM IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE BY 20 FREAKING
POINTS?
[LAUGHTER]
GO TO YOUR SCREEN.
GO TO YOUR SCREEN RIGHT NOW AND
SCRATCH.
WHAT DOES THAT SMELL LIKE TO
YOU, VIEWERS?
LOSER.
WE WOULD HAVE ACCEPTED AX BODY
SPRAY.
THIS GUY COULD NOT WIN A COIN
TOSS IF HE GOT TO CALL BOTH
SIDES.
MEANWHILE, BIDEN'S APPROVAL
RATING WITH HISPANIC AND LATINO
VOTERS SITS IN THE MID-20s.
THAT IS THE WORST OF ANY ETHNIC
GROUP.
GERALDO'S MUSTACHE IS MORE
POPULAR.
AND FOR GOOD REASON.
JOE'S EMBRACING OF HARD LEFT
POLICIES HAS ABANDONED DECENT
PEOPLE OF EVERY PIGMENT AND
EVERY RACE.
THEY SAID HE WAS A UNITER, AND
NOW PEOPLE OF ALL RACES THINK
CAPTAIN POO-POO PANTS SOCKS.
AND IT UNDERMINES EVERYTHING
RACES DEMS HAVE BEEN SAYING FOR
YEARS ABOUT CHANGING
DEMOGRAPHICS.
THEY THOUGHT MEXICANS WOULD BE
DUPES FOR THE HARD LEFT TRIPE.
HOW BIGOTED IS THAT?
>> A LOT OF STATES ARE HEADED
TOWARD INCREASING
DIVERSIFICATION, TOWARD
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES THAT MAKE A
LESS RED STATE FUTURE FOR THEM.
>> I REALLY THINK BECAUSE OF
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES IN THIS
COUNTRY, I THINK THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS GOING TO WIN
TEXAS, MOVING FORWARD, AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS GOING TO BE
IN POWER FOR THE NEXT 30-4
YEARS.
>> THIS SORT OF LONG-TERM
PROJECT OF TRYING TO TAKE SOME
RED STATES ACROSS THE SUN BELT
AND FLIP THEM BLUE, AS
DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGES ARE TAKING
PLACE THERE.
>> THE DEMOGRAPHIC CHANGE THAT
IS HAPPENING IN AMERICA RIGHT
NOW GIVES THE UPPER HAND TO
DEMOCRATS.
>> Greg: WOW.
IT IS ALL MOST LIKE THEY ARE,
DARE I SAY IT, WHITE
SUPREMACISTS IN THEIR THINKING.
THE ASSUMPTION THAT EVERY BROWN
PERSON WILL FALL IN LINE AND
VOTE FOR CRAP IF THEY ARE
PROVIDED FREE STUFF.
DEMS ARE LIKE SURE THEY ARE
PRO-LIFE AND RELIGIOUS, BUT GIVE
FREE DENTAL AND WE WILL ON THEM.
THEY FORGOT HISPANICS ARE NOT AS
PROGRESSIVE AS THE WHITE LIBERAL
ASSUMES.
IT IS WHY YOU ONLY HEAR CLUELESS
WHITES USING THE PHRASE
"LATINX."
>> IT IS HARD, AS WELL, TO GET
LATINX VACCINATED, AS WELL.
WHY?
THEY ARE WORRIED THEY WILL BE
VACCINATED AND DEPORTED.
>> Greg: ALL RIGHT, GRAMPS.
THE FACT IS --
[APPLAUSE]
YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO MUCH.
HE REALLY IS A GODSEND.
IN FACT, MEXICANS ARE JUST LIKE
ANYBODY ELSE.
THEY DO NOT WANT TO BE VICTIMS
OF CRIME.
THAT IS WHY MANY FLED MEXICO,
THEY WANT TO DRINK WATER THAT
DOES NOT DOUBLE AS A LAXATIVE.
BUT THE LEFT WANT THEM TO DROP A
HUNDRED GRAND ON AN ELECTRIC CAR
AND THEY EAT CRICKETS.
UNLIKE THE LEFT, THEY GO TO
CHURCH, BELIEVE IN GOD,
PRO-LIFE, THINK FAMILY IS A GOOD
AND, BASICALLY EISENHOWER
REPUBLICANS PURELY UNDERSTAND
THE HIERARCHY OF NEEDS, SEE THE
LITTLE CHARD?
STUFF LIKE FOOD AND FAMILY, THAT
COMES FIRST, A FAR CRY FROM
PRONOUNS, STATUTE TOPPLING,
INSURRECTION PORN.
THE LEAST IMPORTANT THING ON
THAT CHART, SELF ACTUALIZATION.
WE DON'T EVEN KNOW WHAT THAT IS.
BUT THE REPUBLICAN PARTY GETS
THIS, THAT WE ARE ALL UNITED BY
COMMON SENSE, A WORKING
KNOWLEDGE OF HOME DEPOT, AS WELL
AS THE PLEASURES OF A FINE
TEQUILA.
BUT THE DEMS, THANKS TO THEIR
DELUSIONAL EMBRACE OF WOKEISM,
HAVE IT BACKWARDS.
HERE IS THE LEFT'S HIERARCHY OF
NEEDS.
[LAUGHTER]
CALL EVERYONE RACIST.
BLAME EVERYTHING ON AMERICA.
OPPRESSION.
[APPLAUSE]
NEVER BATHE.
HERE IS JOE'S HIERARCHY OF
NEEDS.
[LAUGHTER]
BLAME OTHER PEOPLE FOR FAILURES.
FILL OUT HUNTER.
WATCH "MURDER SHE WROTE."
FIND ICE CREAM.
NAP.
THAT IS ACTUALLY NOT BAD.
NO WONDER THE DEMS CHASE A
POINTLESS [BLEEP].
THAT IS BECAUSE WITHOUT
STRUCTURE, WORK, OR FAMILY, YOU
END UP WITH MORONIC PLATITUDES,
YOU WILL OWN NOTHING, BUT SO
WHAT?
YOU HAVE 64 GENDERS TO CHOOSE
FROM AND GOVERNMENT WILL MAIL
YOU A CRACK PIPE.
THAT IS THE HUNTER PLAN.
THE LAST TIME A DEMOCRAT MADE
SOMETHING, THEY BECAME A
REPUBLICAN.
[APPLAUSE]
SO, WHO IS --
I'M SURE BY NOVEMBER SHE WILL BE
THE NEW FACE OF WHITE SUPREMACY.
FOR MY SPANISH SPEAKING FRIENDS
AT HOME, --
[SPEAKING SPANISH]
LET'S WELCOME TONIGHT'S GUESTS!
AUTHOR OF THE CHILDREN'S BOOK
"WHY IS MOMMY NAPPING AT
2:00 P.M.," FOX NEWS ANCHOR
JULIE BANDERAS.
>> I THOUGHT YOU WERE GOING TO
HER, I WAS LIKE, SHE WROTE A
BOOK, AMAZING.
SPEAK ONE HE IS
>> Greg: HE IS SOPATRIOTIC THE Y
ONCE HIT ON HIM.
AUTHOR OF THE NEW BOOK "BATTLE
FOR THE AMERICAN MIND,"
PETE HEGSETH BEARD AND A
BRAND-NEW GUEST, SHE KNOWS
CAMPAIGNING LIKE I KNOW
COMPLAINING.
FORMER DIRECTOR OF PRESS
COMMUNICATIONS FOR TRUMP'S
REELECTION CAMPAIGN, ERIN
PERRINE.
AND HE NEEDS A STEAMROLLER TO
IRON HIS SHIRTS.
WORLD TELEVISION CHAMPION TYRUS!
[APPLAUSE]
JULIE, WHAT IS YOUR NATIONALITY?
YOUR LAST NAME IS BANDERAS.
>> ACTUALLY, MY LAST NAME IS
BIDWELL, BANDERAS IS MADE UP.
BANDERAS IS MADE UP -- IT IS A
LONG STORY, BUT MY LAST NAME IS
BIDWELL, I AM PART COLOMBIAN,
PART BRITISH.
>> Greg: INTERESTING.
I AM GLAD I ASKED.
>> I AM A MIX.
>> Greg: ARE YOU SURPRISED BY
HER WIN?
>> NO, SHE LIVES IN TEXAS.
THEY LIKE LEGAL HISPANICS THERE,
LIKE HER, AND AS A LEGAL
HISPANIC AND THE DAUGHTER OF
MIGRANT WORKERS, SHE IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHY
REPUBLICANS ARE DEFINITELY GOING
TO BE TAKING OVER TEXAS, BECAUSE
THEY DO NOT WANT TO SEE ILLEGALS
THERE ANYMORE AND SHE IS THE
PERFECT EXAMPLE OF WHY DEMOCRATS
SHOULD PROBABLY JUST RETIRE AT
THIS POINT.
>> Greg: THIS IS YOUR
WHEELHOUSE, JUST COINED THAT
PHRASE, DO YOU SEE A RED WAVE?
HOW MANY SEATS DO YOU SEE?
>> WELL, IT IS KIND OF HARD TO
SAY.
I THINK YOU'RE LOOKING AT MORE
LIKE 40ISH SEATS, I DON'T THINK
YOU'RE GOING TO SEE 60-70-80
NUMBER.
>> Greg: WHY NOT?
>> REDISTRICTING.
THERE ARE NOT AS MANY
MIDDLE-OF-THE-ROAD SEATS FOR
DEMS TO FLIP.
I FULLY BELIEVE KEVIN McCARTHY
IS THE NEXT SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
I THINK THE SENATE IS VERY MUCH
IN PLAY, BUT NOT AS MUCH AS THE
HOUSE.
THE HOUSE YOU ARE LIKE 95%
CHANCE WE'RE FLIPPING BACK.
THE SENATE IS A TOUGHER MAP.
>> Greg: BACK TO ME IS NOT A
RED WAVE AT ALL, THAT SHOULD BE
EXPECTED.
WHEN YOU WERE OUT OF POWER, YOU
ARE SUPPOSED TO WIN, RIGHT?
THAT HAPPENED WHEN TRUMP WAS IN,
THEN THE DEMOCRATS ROSE UP, WHEN
OBAMA WAS IN, REPUBLICANS.
IF THEY CAN'T GET 50-60 SEATS,
THEY ARE GOING A BIG
OPPORTUNITY, I WOULD THINK, AND
I AM NO EXPERT.
>> WELL, THAT IS FAIR, BUT IT IS
ALSO --
>> Greg: NO, GREG, YOU ARE AN
EXPERT.
>> YOU ARE AN EXPERT.
>> Greg: THANK YOU.
>> IN SOME THINGS.
>> Greg: NOT MANY.
>> WHETHER OR NOT YOU WANT TO --
I CAN SAY IT IS GOING TO BE A
TOUGHER ROAD TO GET TO 50 OR 60,
JUST BECAUSE YOU HAVE --
>> Greg: FACTOR IN
REDISTRICTING.
>> YOU LOOK AT JERSEY, YOU LOOK
AT NEW YORK.
>> Greg: DO I HAVE TO?
>> NO.
>> Greg: OKAY.
PETE, CONGRATULATIONS ON THE NEW
BOOK.
[APPLAUSE]
>> THANK YOU.
>> Greg: I NOTICED YOU QUOTE
TUCKER BUT NOT ME, I AM NOT AN
INDEX THAT MEANS IT IS I AM NOT
IN THE BOOK.
>> IT IS A FAMILY BOOK, GREG.
YOU ARE NOT USEFUL.
>> Greg: IT IS ALWAYS ABOUT
FAMILY WITH YOU, ISN'T IT?
ALL RIGHT, PETE, YEA OR NAY, RED
WAVE?
>> YEA ON THE RED WAVE, IF YOU
THINK OF THE SENATE MAPPING,
CORRECTLY IF I AM WRONG, 2022,
SENATORS ELECTED SIX YEARS AGO,
2016 WAS A GOOD YEAR FOR TRUMP,
DEFENDING SEATS, NOT AS MANY
DEMOCRAT PICKUPS TO BE HAD ON
THE MAP.
THE HOUSE IS MORE INDICATIVE OF
THE WAVE, IT IS UP EVERY TWO
YEARS.
MAYRA FLORES, YOU LOOK AT HER
AD, I AM THE WIFE OF A BORDER
PATROL AGENT?
WHO LIVES THIS EVERY SINGLE DAY,
AND I LOVE WHAT YOU SAID, IT IS
INHERENTLY RACIST TO ASSUME THAT
A CERTAIN SKIN COLOR WILL VOTE A
CERTAIN WAY.
AND AS YOU SAID, I BELIEVE YOU
SAID CAPTAIN POO-POO PANTS?
>> Greg: YES.
NOT AS GOOD AS BIDWELL.
>> WE WILL BE FINDING THAT OUT.
MENU TOTALLY DEPRIORITIZE THE
THINGS THAT MATTER IN EVERYONE'S
EVERYDAY LIVES, EVEN IF YOUR
PARTY HAS GONE HARD LEFT, WHICH
THEY HAVE COME A VOTERS END UP
REJECTING THAT.
JUST ASK THE D.A. IN
SAN FRANCISCO AND LOS ANGELES.
>> Greg: THAT'S A GOOD POINT.
WHAT DO YOU THINK, TYRUS?
IS IT RACIST TO HAVE VOTED FOR
HER?
>> OF COURSE IT IS.
[LAUGHTER]
THEY SAID SO SEVERAL TIMES.
>> Greg: SHE IS THE NEW FACE
OF WHITE SUPREMACY.
>> THEY NEEDED ONE.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: I MEAN, LARRY ELDER
DID A GOOD JOB FOR A WHILE.
>> LARRY DID HIS PART, BUT HIS
HEART JUST WASN'T IN IT.
>> Greg: HE TRIED.
>> HOPEFULLY IT IS A FRIENDLIER,
MORE FOCUSED WHITE SUPREMACIST
PARTY.
>> Greg: OPENING UP TO WOMEN
AND MEXICAN WOMEN.
>> AND US BLACKS.
IT IS A WHOLE NEW WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
>> Greg: EXACTLY.
>> SHOCKING.
GOING TO MISS THE OLD DAYS.
I JUST ALWAYS JUST DRIVES ME
CRAZY WHEN THEY SAY, AND THE
LATINOS HAVE A PROBLEM WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
WHO DOESN'T?
WHICH GROUP IS HE ABOVE 20?
NO ONE IS CLAIMING HIM.
>> THAT IS THE ONE THING FUNNY
ABOUT WHITE PEOPLE, YOU WON'T
SELL EACH OTHER OUT, YOU WILL
NOT STICK TOGETHER.
BIDEN'S GOING DOWN WITH THE
SHIP, AND THE WHITE PEOPLE ARE
ACTING LIKE HE IS HAVING FUN ON
A RIDE.
NO ONE IS GOING IN.
LOOK AT HIM.
>> Greg: THAT IS SO TRUE.
YEAH, HE IS LIKE THAT ONE
STRAY --
>> YOU GUYS ARE COLD-BLOODED,
MAN.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Greg: OH, WELL.
WE WILL SEE, SHALL WE?
I JUST COINED THAT PHRASE, AS
WE